Most of the modern world operates from a system
of individualism.
A system that puts the fate of the individual
in the hands of the individual.
If you are successful, it is because you worked
hard and smart and you deserve it.
If you are a failure, it is because you didn’t
and you deserve it.
This system of thought and reasoning is widely
endorsed by many of the world’s leading
cultures.
It is the basis of capitalism and arguably
the basis of human nature.
It is the reason why we try.
Why we apply creativity.
Why we compete to progress humankind.
Because we believe that our actions determine
our fate.
That we all control the course of our own
lives.
But this begs the question, how in control
are we really?
How much stake should we place in the ideal
that we are the sole driver of our life?
It appears to be true that we humans do have
some ability to influence the direction in
which our life goes.
Hard work, strategy, and ingenuity can increase
the likeliness of achieving one’s goals
and desired lifestyle.
But it also appears to be true that often
times what we want does not align with what
we get.
That life operates on its own wavelength,
some amount out of reach from our volition
and control.
Fundamentally, we live in a reality that we
do not fully understand.
And as a result, there is an entire realm
of uncertainty and arbitrariness associated
with everything we experience, including our
fortunes and misfortunes.
We are not the sole pilots of our life.
We cannot choose whom we are born to.
Or to avoid a tragedy.
Or to be tall or small, white or black, dumb
or smart.
We are all forced to submit to our DNA and
the instances of luck or tragedy that we are
exposed to in life.
The truth is, things happen.
For good and for bad.
But oftentimes things that happen, happen
just because they happen.
Not because of intent, but because of chance.
And the things that happen out of chance hold
the same amount of weight and influence on
our lives as the things that happen out of
intent.
Humanity may operate out of individuality,
but the universe operates from a place of
collectivity.
And so we must learn how to live with the
burden of existing with an individualistic
mind and culture, while simultaneously existing
within a collective reality.
We should try to do everything in our power
to influence our life.
We should feel motivated and invigorated to
work towards goals and success.
But we should also acknowledge the realm of
life that is beyond our control, so we can
be reasonably indifferent towards the fortunes
and misfortunes we experience so we do not
become disillusioned if our fate does not
align with our intentions or become inflated
with narcissism if it does.
It is not only our achievements that matter.
Wealthy or poor, smart or foolish, famous
or unknown, we all remain in the same boat,
just as confused and as vulnerable to life
as the next.
Our quality of life depends on our ability
to admit this, roll with the punches, and
stay inspired to pursue success for the mere
sake of the pursuit.
To function partly as an observer of our own
life, whose primary objective is to be entertained
by life’s uncertainty, for both the good
and
the bad.